qu'on ne s'y trompe pas il nous l'est
pas un groupe d'appartement il est
plutôt taillé pour la scène
piret sabine ont joué dans plusieurs
formations dont blankass mais il voulait
un projet à eux ils ont donc créé l'an
dernier mines ou du rock mais surtout
des textes personnels
quand tu es content quand t'es pas
frustrer honnêtement t'as pas envie
d'écrire
par contre quand à des sentiments qui
sont vachement profond qui sont sa
touche et c'est souvent des sentiments
qui sont qui sont tristes qui peuvent
être de la frustration de la tristesse
des pleins de choses
c'est là que l'on vit vient d'écrire
quelque chose tu as envie de raconter
quelque chose dans vie de partage et
envie de te soulager de quelque chose et
c'est là que tu es généralement qu'on
arrive à écrire et effectivement ça
parle du coup pas mal de racines
thérapie quoi plus ou moins coincé on va
pas chez le petit m'ont fait des
chansons
en concert le duo est accompagné de
charlie à la batterie mais le groupe se
sert beaucoup de l'électronique pour
créer et diffuser dès son achat en place
des personnes comme les six noms mais il
ya un vrai côté ludique dans la mesure
où effectivement tu peux tout de suite
allé chercher un son le travailler
pendant des heure et tout moi j'adore ça
aller trifouiller des sons de claviers
jusqu'à pas de passer des heures dessus
même même si en dix minutes on est
capable de faire une chanson
le groupe vient d'issoudun et
contrairement aux apparences ce n'est
pas si dur de faire du rock en zone
rurale il ya presque pas assez le groupe
ce qui fait que quand tu arrives avec un
projet que quelque chose qui a un peu
ficelé et qui peut qui peut tout de
suite joué nous on a vachement été aidés
tout de suite on nous a ouvert les
portes des salles à issoudun on nous a
ouvert les portes de plein de choses
pour qu'on puisse créer à avancer
le groupe a mis ses premiers titres en
écoute sur internet il s'apprête à
sortir un disque et sera en concert cet
été dans la région
première date le 19 juillet à tauxigny
en indre et loire